So we're not through with the amazing story
of the CCR5 delta 32 allele yet. Another
really interesting fact about it, is now it's
believed that the CCR5 delta 32 recessive allele also
conferred resistance to the Bubonic plague during the
pandemic known as The Black Death which struck Europe
in 1347 and killed 1 3rd of the
world's population. So people with two copies of CCR5
delta 32 allele had a higher survival rate.
And today the highest frequency of this allele
is in northern Europe. So your fourth question
in this saga of CCR5, is this selection pressure,
for it to be in northern Europe, is
this an example of natural selection or random
selection? I want you to pick one and
then justify your answer in the text box here.